FEMALE SPEAKER: The following
content is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Our subject matter today
concerns that phase of
calculus known as the
'indefinite integral', or the
'antiderivative'.
In terms of the concepts that
we've talked about so far in
our course, and keeping in mind
that one concept with
many applications is
educationally more meaningful
than many concepts each with one
application, I prefer to
call today's lesson the inverse
derivative, or inverse
differentiation.
And again, bring into play a
very well-known feature of our
course, namely, our discussion
of inverse functions.
Now, you see, the only problem
that comes up in this context
is a rather simple one and that
is that all the time that
we've been taking a derivative,
we may not have
realized that we were using the
idea of a function in a
rather different way.
Namely, noticed that by taking
a derivative, we had a rule
which told us how, given a
particular function, to assign
to it a new function called
its 'derivative'.
In other words, what we could
have done is to have
visualized a different function
machine, which I will
call the 'D-machine'.
Hopefully, the 'D' will suggest
differentiation, where
the domain of my the machine--
in other words, the input of
my 'D-machine' will be
differentiable functions and the
output, you see, the image
of my 'D-machine' will
be the derivative of
that particular function.
So in other words then, if we
want to use our typical
notation, what we're
saying is that the
'D-machine' does what?
Given a differentiable function
as its input, the
output will be the derivative
'f prime'.
Now again, we're used to talking
about the derivative
with respect to a
given variable.
Unless otherwise specified,
the variable is 'x'.
And so, perhaps with that in
mind, maybe it would be more
suggestive if I were to do
something like this to
indicate, you see, that the
input is 'f of x' and the
output is 'f prime of x'.
Now, you may recall also that
long before we started dealing
with functions of real
variables, we discussed
functions in general
in terms of circle
diagrams and the like.
In this respect, notice that
we can think of our
'D-machine' as operating on a
particular domain, the domain
being what?
The set of all differentiable
functions.
And the range, or the image,
will also be what?
All functions which
are derivatives of
differentiable functions.
Now, what kind of a
function is 'D'?
Don't lose track of the
fact that things like
one-to-oneness and ontoness are
concepts that transcend
dealing with numbers.
They apply whenever
we're dealing with
any kind of a function.
The idea is something
like this.
If 'x squared' were to go into
the 'D-machine', the output
would be '2x'.
See? 'x squared' is
mapped into '2x'.
'x cubed' is mapped into
'3 x squared'.
See, the derivative of 'x cubed'
with respect to 'x' is
'3 x squared'.
'x squared plus 7', also
mapped into '2x'.
In other words, without going
any further, notice that
whatever 'D' is, 'D'
is not 1 to 1.
You see, two different functions
can have the same
derivative.
In fact, many different
functions can have the same
derivative.
For example, once we know that
the derivative of 'x squared'
is '2x', we certainly know
that the derivative of 'x
squared' plus any constant
is also '2x'.
In other words then, we cannot
make an inverse function
machine as things stand here.
And why is that?
To have an inverse function,
what you must be able to do is
to reverse arrowheads and
still have a function.
Notice that, in a way, 'D
inverse' would be a little bit
of a tricky thing to
talk about here.
But let's pretend that
we could anyway.
In other words, what would go
wrong if we tried to build a
'D' inverse machine?
Well, in terms of the example
that we're talking about, if
the input to the D inverse
machine happened to be '2x',
then there would be infinitely
many different outputs that
we're sure of.
Namely what?
Every function of the form
'x squared plus c'
where 'c' is a constant.
And what do I mean, we can
be sure of that many?
You see, all I know going back
to this diagram here is that
every function of the form 'x
squared plus c' will map into
'2x' under the derivative
function.
The other question that comes
up is, how do you know that
you can find a function whose
derivative is '2x' that comes
from a function which doesn't
have the form 'x
squared plus c'?
How do you know there isn't some
other function 'f of x'
which has the property that
'f of x' maps into '2x'?
In other words, the derivative
of 'f of x' is '2x' even
though 'f of x' does not have
the form 'x squared plus c'.
And this is exactly where the
mean value theorem comes in to
help us over here.
You see, what we're saying here
is, suppose that 'D' of
'f of x' is '2x'.
All we know is that when you
run 'f of x' through the
'D-machine', you wind
up with '2x'.
What does that mean?
'f prime of x' is '2x'.
Well, we know the derivative of
'x squared' is also '2x'.
Therefore, whatever 'f of x'
is by the corollary to the
mean value theorem that we've
studied before, since 'f of x'
and 'x squared' have identical
derivatives, namely, they're
both '2x', it means that they
must differ by a constant.
In other words, 'f of x' minus
'x squared' is a constant.
But to say that 'f of x' minus
'x squared' is a constant is
the same as saying that 'f of
x' belongs to the family 'x
squared plus c'.
In other words, 'f
of x' equals 'x
squared' plus a constant.
What the mean value theorem
tells us is not only does
every function of the form 'x
squared plus c' have its
derivative equal to '2x' but
that every function whose
derivative is '2x' has the
form 'x squared plus c'.
To generalize this, consider
the following.
Suppose we're given
'f of x', OK?
And we now say, look, every
time you differentiate a
function, if you add on a
constant, you don't change
anything, meaning what?
The derivative of
a constant is 0.
In other words, what we're
saying is, if the derivative
of 'f of x' is 'f prime of x',
any function of the form 'f of
x' plus 'c' will have
the same derivative.
And not only that, the only
function whose derivative is
'f prime of x' must
be one of these.
That's what this 'e
sub f' stands for.
You see, what I'm really saying
here is that certainly
when you change the constant,
you change the function.
The point is, with respect
to the thing called the
derivative, you cannot tell
the difference between two
functions just by looking at
their derivatives if they
differ by a constant.
In other words, with respect
to differentiation, two
functions which differ by a
constant are equivalent and
that's why I invented this
notation, 'e of f'.
All I'm saying is that if we
visualize now that the input
of the 'D-machine' is not
individual functions but whole
classes of functions--
in other words, such that they
differ only by a constant,
then you see there is a
one-to-one correspondence
between the input
and the output.
Now that's a subtle point.
It's a point which I'm sure
most of you will grasp.
But more importantly, the
important thing is simply that
once we've seen one function
with a given derivative, in a
manner of speaking, we've
seen them all.
In other words, we only have
enough leeway as to fool
around with an arbitrary
constant.
So let's generalize again.
What do we mean by 'D inverse'
of 'f of x'?
We mean what?
The set of all function 'g of
x' whose derivative with
respect to 'x' is the
given 'f of x'.
See, that's exactly what the
inverse function means.
And by the way, notice that
this tells me my set
implicitly.
Let me put that in parentheses
over here.
Namely, suppose somebody says,
does 'g of x' belong to this
particular set called
'D inverse'?
All I have to do is
differentiate the given 'g'
and see if I get 'f'.
If I do, 'G' belongs
to the set.
If I don't, it doesn't
belong to the set.
But as we've so often stressed
about inverse functions,
notice that the test to see
whether something belongs to
'D inverse', it's sufficient to
know how to differentiate.
By the way, to summarize what
we did before, to list this
thing explicitly, notice that
what we're saying is, to find
the set of all functions whose
derivative is little 'f of x',
all we have to do is what?
Find one function, capital
'F', whose derivative is
little 'f'.
And then our set, explicitly,
is what?
The set of all functions of the
form capital 'F of x' plus
'c' where 'c' is an arbitrary
constant.
Now, I'm sure this
concept is not
difficult for you to grasp.
For those of you who have been
through calculus before, as
our course is intended to be for
this type of person too,
you see, you may not be familiar
with the notation,
the 'D inverse' notation, which
I want to stress here.
But the concept, I hope, is
clear in its own right.
Now of course, you see, the
problem that comes up is that
it's much easier to
differentiate a function than
it is to be given a function and
then have to try to find
what you have to differentiate
to get it.
Without meaning it as
facetiously as it may sound, I
use this in on many occasions,
I prefer to say is much
easier, you see, to scramble an
egg than to unscramble one.
Told what to differentiate,
that's easy enough to do.
Given the derivative, that
may not be so easy.
Let's look in terms
of an example.
But this is, again, a very
nice teachers trick.
To get the right answer, you
start with the answer and then
work to the problem.
I'll start with the function 'h
of x' equals 'x' times the
'square root of 'x
squared plus 1''.
Or written more conveniently in
exponential notation, 'x'
times ''x squared plus
1' to the 1/2'.
Let me differentiate that.
Remember, this is a product.
The derivative of a
product is what?
It's the first factor which is
'x' times the derivative of
the second.
That means what?
I bring the 1/2 down to a
power 1 less, times the
derivative of what's inside
with respect to 'x'.
See, the some old chain
rule again.
That's '2x'.
Then what?
Plus the second factor, 'x
squared plus 1' to the 1/2
times the derivative of the
first with respect to 'x',
which is 1.
At any rate, simplifying,
bringing the minus 1/2 power
into the denominator, then
putting everything over a
common denominator, I wind up
with the fact that 'h prime of
x' is '2 x squared plus 1' over
the 'square root of 'x
squared plus 1''.
I hope I haven't made a
careless error here.
But again, one of the beauties
of the new mathematics is that
it's the method that's
important, OK?
Now, at any rate,
what do I know?
Starting with 'h of x' equaling
'x' times the 'square
root of 'x squared plus 1'', I
now know that its derivative
is '2 x squared plus 1' over
the 'square root of 'x
squared plus 1''.
Let's write that in terms of
our 'D inverse' notation.
Namely, what we're saying is
that 'x' times the 'square
root of 'x squared plus 1''
has the property that its
derivative is '2 x squared plus
1' over the 'square root
of 'x squared plus 1''.
Consequently, every function
which has the property that
its derivative is '2 x squared
plus 1' over the 'square root
of 'x squared plus 1'' must
come from this family.
You see?
Everything of this form
we'll have its
derivative equal to this.
And secondly, any other function
cannot have its
derivative equal to this by
our corollary to the mean
value theorem.
Now you see, what
I'm saying is--
and here's the beauty of what we
mean by inverse operations
and the like.
It's conceivable that you
might not have been
sophisticated enough at this
stage in the game to have been
able to deduce this had
we been given this.
Notice that my cute trick was I
started with this, found out
what the derivative
was, and then just
inverted the emphasis.
A change in emphasis again.
However, notice the following.
Suppose you weren't
able to find this.
And somebody said to you, I
wonder if 'x' times the
'square root of 'x squared plus
1'' is a function whose
derivative is equal to this.
And all I'm saying, without
going through the work again
because I've already done that,
is to simply observe
that even if you did not know
this explicit representation,
by definition, 'D inverse' of '2
x squared plus 1' over the
'square root of 'x squared
plus 1'' is simply what?
The set of all functions 'g of
x' such that 'g prime of x' is
equal to '2 x squared plus 1'
over the 'square root of 'x
squared plus 1''.
In other words, given any
function at all, I could
differentiate it.
If the derivative came
out to be this,
then I have a solution.
It belongs to the
solution set.
Otherwise, it doesn't.
But again, notice that's to
solve any 'D inverse' problem,
it's sufficient to understand a
corresponding derivative property.
In fact, maybe now is a good
time to show how we get
certain recipes for 'D
inverse' type things.
Let me just write down
a typical one.
You see, 'D inverse of 'x to the
n'' is 'x to the 'n + 1''
over 'n + 1' plus a constant.
And of course, observe that as
soon as you see something like
this, you have to beware of
'n' equals negative 1.
Otherwise we have
a 0 denominator.
Now, a person says, this doesn't
look familiar to me.
Again, keep in mind what
D inverse means.
Essentially, to say this is just
a switch in emphasis from
saying what?
That if you run the family of
functions 'x to the 'n + 1''
over 'n + 1' plus a constant
through your 'D-machine', you
get 'x to the n'.
Or more familiarly, what?
The derivative of any member in
this family is 'x to the n'
provided that 'n' is not
equal to minus 1.
Now again, this may look a
little bit abstract to you.
So to avoid this problem,
let's just do a concrete
illustration.
Let's pick a particular
value of 'n' and
work with this thing.
Let's suppose we're told to
determine 'D inverse'
of 'x to the 7th'.
What does that mean?
What it really means is, let's
find a function whose
derivative is 'x to the 7th'.
And why do I say let's
find a function?
Because once I find a function,
all I have to do is
tack on arbitrary constants and
the family that I get that
way is the unique family of
functions which have this
particular derivative.
So I play the detective game.
I know from differential
calculus that if I
differentiate 'x' to the 8th
power, I'll wind up with the
exponent 7, at least.
In other words, the derivative
of 'x' to the 8th power.
'D of 'x to the 8th'' is
'8 'x to the 7th''.
Well, what answer did
I want to get?
I wanted to get 'x to the 7th',
not '8 'x to the 7th''.
So I fudge this thing
a little bit.
I say, evidently what I should
have done was to have started
with 1/8 as much.
In other words, multiplying
equals by equals, I multiply
both sides of this equation by
1/8 and I wind up with '1/8 D
'x to the 8th'' equals
'x to the 7th'.
And now comes a very
crucial step.
And let me write that down
because I think it's something
that we should pay very
close attention to.
And that is that the derivative
has the property
that if you want to
differentiate a constant times
a function, you can take the
constant out and differentiate
just the function.
This is a very crucial point
because you see--
and by the way, notice that in
general, not all functions
have this property.
For example, if you're squaring
something, if you
double the number that's being
squared, the output is 4 times
as much because twice
something squared
is 4 times as much.
In other words, in general,
you do not say that if you
double the input, you're going
to double the output.
Not every function has
that property.
But the function called 'D', the
derivative, does have this
particular property.
And you see, with that
in mind, I can
bring this 1/8 inside.
This is the key step, that 1/8
times the derivative of 'x to
the 8th' is a derivative of
''1/8' x to the 8th'.
That's this key step
over here.
And now, you see, putting all
this together, I find what?
That the derivative of
''1/8' x to the 8th'
is 'x to the 7th'.
And therefore, since I found one
function whose derivative
is 'x to the 7th', I have, in
a sense, found them all,
namely, ''1/8' x to
the 8th' plus 'c'.
In other words, that's what I
call the equivalent class of
''1/8' x to the 8th'.
All the functions that differ
from ''1/8' x to
the 8th' by a constant.
And again, to emphasize this
very important point, let me
again mention, beware of
non-constant factors.
Let me give you a
for instance.
Let's suppose I take almost
the same problem.
And that almost as
a big almost.
Let's suppose I say, let me
find all functions whose
derivative, say, is 'x squared
plus 1' to the 7th power.
In other words, still something
to the 7th power.
So I argue something like,
well, since whenever I
differentiate I reduce the
exponent by 1, to wind up with
a 7th power, maybe
I should have
started with an 8th power.
So I say, OK, that's
what I'll do.
I'll start with an 8th power.
So I say, OK, what is the
derivative of 'x squared plus
1' to the 8th power?
Now notice I know how to
differentiate, hopefully.
And again, let me make this
point very strongly.
There is no sense studying
inverse functions if we don't
know the original
function itself.
Because the whole purpose of the
inverse function, or the
whole strategy behind it, is to
reduce it to the original
function, namely, to switch
the emphasis.
So at any rate, I differentiate
'x squared plus
1' to the 8th power.
I get '8 'x squared plus
1' to the 7th'.
But now, by the chain rule, I
must remember that this part
was only the derivative with
respect to 'x squared plus 1'.
The correction factor is what?
The derivative of what's inside
with respect to 'x'.
That's '2x'.
And so I wind up with that if
I differentiate ''x squared
plus 1' to the 8th', I get '16x'
times ''x squared plus
1' to the 7th'.
Now, how much did
I want to get?
I wanted to get just ''x squared
plus 1' to the 7th'.
That put me off by a
factor of '16x'.
Now I say, OK, I'll
fix that up.
Namely, I'll divide both sides
by '16x', assuming, of course,
that 'x' is not 0.
And this, by the way,
is perfectly valid.
I can now go from here to here
and say, look, '1 over 16x'
times the derivative of ''x
squared plus 1' to the 8th'
with respect to 'x' is ''x
squared plus 1' to the 7th'.
However, notice that I cannot
take this factor and bring it
inside here.
And again, as I so often have
said, also, of course I can
bring it inside here.
I just did.
What I mean is, I don't
get the right answer.
And what's the best proof that
I don't get the right answer?
Very, very simple.
Take this function,
differentiate it, and see if
you get ''x squared plus
1' to the 7th'.
You won't, unless you
differentiate incorrectly.
Don't be like the person who
just differentiates, brings
the 8 down, replaces this by
1 less, multiplies by a
derivative of what's inside,
and cancels everything out.
Notice that the expression
inside the brackets that I've
just circled is a quotient.
And the derivative of a quotient
is obtained in a very
special way.
The denominator times the
derivative of the numerator
minus the numerator times the
derivative of the denominator
over the square of
the denominator.
And all I'm saying is, you won't
get ''x squared plus 1'
to the 7th' power
if you do that.
Again, notice that you do not
have to know the right answer
in order to see what answer
is wrong, OK?
So this would be
a wrong answer.
By the way, this would also be
a wrong answer because we've
already seen that the derivative
of ''1/8' x squared
plus 1' to the 8th
power is what?
You bring the 8 down, which
kills off the 1/8.
You replace this to a power of
one less, which gives you ''x
squared plus 1' to the 7th'.
But the correction factor here
is you must also multiply by a
derivative of what's inside
with respect to 'x'.
And that's to '2x'.
In other words, you do
not get ''x squared
plus 1' to the 7th'.
What you do get is what? ''x
squared plus 1' to the 7th'
times '2x'.
And the question that may now
come up is, how come this
worked when you were raising
'x' to the 8th power but it
didn't work when you were
raising 'x squared plus 1' to
the 8th power?
Again, as always in these
cases, the answer is
immediately available in
terms of derivatives.
We can talk, in fact, about
the inverse chain rule.
That when we really
talked about 'D'--
remember, we mentioned this at
the very beginning of the
lecture, that the variable
inside the parentheses was the
one with respect to which you
were differentiating.
In other words, what we saw was
that if you wanted to get
something to the 7th power, what
you had to differentiate
was 1/8 that same something to
the 8th power if you were
differentiating with respect
to that same variable.
In other words, what would have
been ''x squared plus 1'
to the 7th' would
have been what?
If you would differentiating
not with respect to 'x' but
with respect to 'x
squared plus 1'.
See, what we really wanted when
we wrote this down was
the derivative with
respect to 'x'.
And even though this notation
may look a little bit strange
to you, observe that once you
get used to the notation, this
is just another way of talking
about the chain rule.
Namely, to find the derivative
of this with respect to 'x',
you first take the derivative
with respect to 'x squared
plus 1' and then multiply that
by the derivative of 'x
squared plus 1' with
respect to 'x'.
And if we do that, you see, we
get the answer that we've
talked about before.
In other words, what we could
say is that the function that
you have to differentiate to get
''x squared plus 1' to the
7th' times '2x' is ''1/8' x
squared plus 1' to the 8th'
plus a constant.
And how do I know that?
Well, the way I know that
is simply what?
In terms of inverse functions,
I started with ''1/8' x
squared plus 1' to the 8th',
differentiated it and found
out I got ''x squared plus 1'
to the 7th' times '2x'.
And so this became the recipe.
And again, a rather interesting
aside, if you look
at this, and look at this, it
would appear at first glance
that the top one should be a
more difficult problem than
the bottom one.
The reason being that the input
seems more simple in the
bottom one.
Yet, the interesting point is
that the '2x', which seems to
make this thing more
complicated, is precisely the
factor you need by the chain
rule to make this thing work.
Because when you differentiate
'x squared plus 1' to the 8th
power, you're going to
get a factor of '2x'
by the chain rule.
Now again, the main aim of the
lectures is not to take the
place of the computational
drill supplied in our
exercises and in the
text but to give
you sort of an insight.
And they'll be plenty of drill
on the mechanics of this in
our exercises on this section.
Let me just at least continue
on with the
concept of our recipes.
For example, here's
another one.
And this one says what?
That if you run the sum of two
functions through the 'D
inverse' machine, the output is
the same as if you sent the
functions through separately
and then added them up, OK?
I'll talk about that in
more detail later.
Again, all I want to see is
that this is the analogous
result of, again, a beautiful
property of the derivative.
And that is that the derivative
of a sum is the sum
of the derivatives.
And how does that
work over here?
Again, a very interesting
property throughout advanced
calculus, linear algebra
and the like.
These properties are
very, very special.
And we'll have occasion, as the
course goes on, to talk
about them more.
For the time being, rather than
have you get lost in the
maze of details, let me work
a specific illustration.
Let's suppose I would like to
find the family of functions
whose derivative is 'x to the
5th' plus 'x cubed', OK?
Now, what I'm saying is this.
By my previous result, I
certainly know how to find the
function whose derivative is 'x
to the 5th', namely, ''1/6'
x to the 6th'.
I also know how to find the
function whose derivative is
'x cubed', namely, '1/4'
x to the 4th'.
Putting these two steps together
and say equals added
to equals are equal, I can
conclude that 'D of ''1/6' x
to the sixth'' plus 'D of ''1/4'
x to the fourth'' is 'x
to the 5th' plus 'x cubed'.
Now, the key step is that since
the derivative of a sum
is the sum of the derivatives,
I can say that the sum of
these two derivatives is the
derivative of the sum of the
two functions.
Namely, that this is what?
'D of ''1/6' x to the 6th'' plus
''1/4' x to the 4th', a
very important power and
property of the derivative.
Therefore, have I found one
function whose derivative is
'x to the 5th' plus 'x cubed'?
The answer is yes. ''1/6'
x to the 6th' plus
''1/4' x to the 4th'.
Therefore, what is the family
of all functions whose
derivative is 'x 5th'
plus 'x cubed'?
And again, as before, the
answer is, take your one
solution that you found, tack on
an arbitrary constant, and
I suppose, technically speaking,
I should put the
braces in here to indicate
that my solution is an
infinite set, all belonging
to one family called an
equivalent set of functions
because they have the same
derivative.
Well, let's continue
on and do a little
bit more harder stuff.
Remember, we talked about
implicit differentiation.
Well, is there an analogue
to implicit 'D inverses'?
You see, notice that in every
problem so far, when I wrote
'D inverse', I was essentially
telling you explicitly what
came out of the 'D-machine'.
Now, suppose I twist the
emphasis a little bit.
Suppose I tell you, look, I run
a certain function through
the 'D-machine'.
In other words, I form
its derivative.
What the output is, is the
square of the reciprocal of
the function.
In other words, if 'g of x'
comes in, '1 over 'g of x''
squared comes out.
And now the question is, what
is the function 'g of x'?
And again, notice that if we
don't know what the right 'g
of x', is you can certainly test
a given 'g of x' to see
whether it's right or not.
Namely, what could you do?
You differentiate 'g of x', see
what you get, and if what
you get isn't 1 over the square
of 'g of x', you've got
the wrong answer.
But the question that comes up
is, given this type of a
problem, how do we handle it?
See?
In other words, where does the
inverse idea come in here?
The implicit relationship that
'g of x' is determined by this
particular property.
And again, notice how we use
properties of derivatives.
We're given that 'g prime of x'
is a synonym, identity, for
'1 over 'g squared of x'.
We can cross-multiply and we get
'g squared of x' times 'g
prime of x' is identically
one.
Now, if you're clever about
this-- and remember, notice
this very, very importantly.
For example, ordinary division
is the inverse of ordinary
multiplication.
Notice that to be really cute
in division, you have to be
pretty cute in multiplication.
Since all you're doing is
changing the emphasis, notice
that to handle hard problems in
antiderivatives, you have
to be able to handle tough
derivative problems.
What I'm driving at is, you look
at something like this
and begin to wonder, do you
know a function whose
derivative is this?
See?
The idea is, if you're familiar
with your chain rule,
what is the derivative
of 'g cubed of x'?
To differentiate 'g cubed',
what do you do?
You bring the 3 down to a
power 1 less times the
derivative of 'g of x'
with respect to 'x'.
That's your chain rule.
That's 'g prime of x'.
In other words, if you're clever
enough to see this,
what you say here is, OK, now
I multiply both sides by 3.
The left hand side is just the
derivative of 'g cubed of x'.
The right hand side is the
derivative off '3x'.
Therefore, whatever g of x
is, its cube has the same
derivative with respect
to 'x' as '3x'.
And we've already learned that
if two functions have
identical derivatives,
they differ
by, at most, a constant.
Consequently, 'g cubed
of x' must equal
'3x' plus some constant.
In other words, 'g of x' is the
cube root of '3x plus c'.
Now, time is running short in
terms of other things that I
want to teach you in
today's lesson.
Let me leave this, then,
just for you to check.
Simply differentiate the cube
root of '3x plus c'.
And make sure that when you get
that derivative, it does
turn out to be '1 over
'g of x' squared'.
As I say, it's a straightforward
demonstration.
I leave the details to you.
But the point that's really
important is that whenever you
do get an answer--
the hard part is to
get the answer.
Whenever you do get the answer,
you can check by means
of just taking a derivative.
Now, with all of this talk about
'D inverse' in mind, let
me now go back to the more
traditional notation, the
notation that you'll find in
most textbooks, the notation
that, as I say, if you've had
calculus before, most likely,
you're more familiar with.
And that is the following, that
when we write 'D inverse'
of 'f of x', the average
textbook writes
a symbol like this.
It's called the 'integral'
of 'f of x'.
I will have later lectures to
bemoan this choice of notation
from a different
point of view.
But for the time being, all
we're saying is, instead of
writing 'D inverse'--
again, what's in the name?
Just use this particular
notation.
That when you see this
particular thing, perhaps read
this as what?
That this particular symbol is a
code to tell you to find all
functions whose derivative
is 'f of x'.
And by the way, to summarize
the results that we've
obtained so far, let me just
rewrite some of these basic
results in terms of the more
traditional notation.
When you write this, this is
called the 'indefinite
integral' and what we're saying
is the indefinite
integral of ''x to the n' dx' is
'x to the 'n + 1'' over 'n
+ 1' plus a constant when it
is not equal to minus 1.
The integral of a sum is the
sum of the integrals.
And the integral of a constant
times a function is a constant
times the integral.
All this says is what?
That this is a consequent of the
fact that the derivative
of the sum is the sum
of the derivatives.
This is a consequent of the fact
that the derivative of a
constant times a function is
the constant times the
derivative of the function.
And again, all this is, same
thing we were talking about
before only with the 'D inverse'
notation replaced by
the more common indefinite
integral.
Now, we come to one more problem
which will finish us
up for the day, once we get
through talking about it.
And that's this.
If all this means is find the
functions whose derivative is
'f of x', why write this
notation here?
Why couldn't we have just
written, for example, the
so-called integral sign with
a little 'x' underneath?
You see, we've talked about
misleading notations before.
You see, in terms of our
differential notation, when
you see ''f of x' dx', you have
every right to think of a
differential.
Now, in all fairness, the
chances are that this notation
would not have been invented
if there weren't some
connection between derivatives
and differentials.
So let me mention this point.
Going back as if we were
starting the lecture all over
again, could I have invented a
different machine, which I'll
call the 'script D- machine'?
In other words, I don't want
to call it the same
'D-machine' as before because
now it's going to have a
different set of outputs.
You see, now the input
will still be
differentiable functions.
But the output, instead of being
the derivative of the
function, will be the
differential of the function.
For example, before,
we said what?
If 'x squared' goes in, the
output would be '2x'.
With the script 'D-machine', the
output would be '2x dx'.
Now, even though these machines
are different because
one machine gives you a
differential as an output and
the other gives you a derivative
as an output,
notice that they
are equivalent.
Namely, knowing the
differential, we can pin down
the function the same as when
we knew the derivative.
Now, the question that comes up
is, why should we use this
particular type of notation?
And to use the examples that are
most prevalent in the text
and also in our notes, let me
give you the same problem that
we've done before,
but now from a
different point of view.
Suppose we're still given the
problem 'g prime of x' equals
'1 over 'g of x' squared'.
We say, OK, let 'y'
equal 'g of x'.
When we do that, this problem
now translates into what?
'dy dx' equals '1 over
'y squared''.
Now, if we allow ourselves to
use the differential notation,
which we justified in previous
lectures, this says what?
Cross-multiplying ''y squared'
dy' equals 'dx'.
Notice, by the way, that 'y' is
implicitly a differentiable
function of 'x'.
So what we're saying over here
is, look, here are two
functions which have the same
differential, therefore, if we
integrate them, they differ
by a constant.
Well, to mimic what we were
doing before, let's just say--
let's see, this, I
think, I have a
little bit twisted here.
If ''y squared' dy' equals
'3x', '3 'y squared' dy'
equals '3dx'.
If the differentials are equal,
then the functions
differ by a constant.
But 'y cubed' is the function
whose differential is '3 'y
squared' dy'.
'3x' is the function whose
differential is '3dx'.
And we wind up with 'y cubed'
equals '3x + c', or, 'y'
equals the 'cube root
of '3x + c''.
By the way, let me just pull
this board down so that we can
make a little bit of
a comparison here.
You see, notice that in using
this differential notation,
which allowed us to use some
nice algebraic devices and
didn't seem quite as difficult
for us to recognize certain
things, I hope you notice
that there seems to be a
correspondence between the steps
that we had here and the
steps that took place
over here.
In other words, having done at
the so-called rigorous way,
notice that differentials
give us a very nice,
intuitively-simpler technique
for solving certain types of
problems when we have implicit
relationships
between 'y' and 'x'.
And so, just to illustrate
this in terms of one more
problem, let's take one that's
fairly geometric.
Let's suppose we're given
the following problem.
'dy dx' is 'minus x' over 'y'
and we know that when 'x'
equals 3, 'y' equals 4.
Using the language of
differentials, what we would
do over here is we would
cross-multiply.
Whatever you want to do.
we recognize that, to get '2y',
you must differentiate
'y squared'.
This is a step you don't
really need.
I don't care how you
want to do this.
All I'm saying is that from this
step, I can get to here.
Recognizing that y squared has
'2y dy' as its differential
and that ''minus 'x squared''
has 'minus 2x dx' as its
differential, I know that 'y
squared' is equal to ''minus
'x squared'' plus a constant.
I transpose.
I get that 'x squared' plus
'y squared' is a constant.
Knowing that when 'x' equals
3, 'y' equals 4, I can
determine that the constant must
be 25 when 'x' equals 3
and 'y' is 4.
But since it's a constant, if
it's 25 when 'x' equals 3 and
'y' equals 4, it's
25 everyplace.
And again, if you want a
geometric interpretation of
this, the circle centered at the
origin with radius equal
to 5 is the only curve in the
whole world whose derivative
at any given point is the
negative of the x-coordinate
over the y-coordinate
and passes through
the point (3 , 4).
And if you want to see that
geometrically, let me just
take a second here.
You see, notice that any point
on the circle (x , y), notice
that the tangent line to the
curve, which has slope 'dy
dx', is what?
Perpendicular to the
radius, again.
The radius has slope
'y' over 'x'.
And to be perpendicular--
if two lines are perpendicular,
their slopes
are negative reciprocals.
This is this particular
problem.
And now, all I wanted to show
you is that if you're nervous
about differentials and you
don't like to use them, notice
that the same problem could
have been stated without
differentials.
Namely, we are thinking of a
function which we'll call 'g
of x' such that the derivative
of 'g of x' is 'minus
x' over 'g of x'.
In other words, if the input of
the 'D-machine' is 'g', the
output is 'minus x' over 'g'.
And we also know that when 'x'
equals 3, the output is 4.
So to 'g' of 3 equals 4.
And without going through the
great details here, let's just
notice that we could
cross-multiply the same as before.
We could multiply both sides
by 2, the same as before.
We could recognize that the
left-hand side was the
derivative of ''g of x'
squared', that the right-hand
side is the derivative of
'minus 'x squared''.
Therefore, since they have the
same identical derivatives,
they must differ
by a constant.
OK.
We actually have plus or minus
here, but notice the fact that
when the input is 3, the output
is 4 means that we're
on the positive branch of
the curve, et cetera.
I say et cetera not because
these points aren't important
but because every point that
comes up now has already been
discussed under the heading
of differential calculus.
In other words, that the inverse
of differentiation can
be handled very, very neatly
just by knowing
differentiation with a
switch in emphasis.
Why do we want to know this
particular topic?
Well, because in many cases, to
look at it geometrically,
in the past, we were
given the curve.
We wanted to find out
what the slope was.
In many physical applications,
we are, in a sense, told what
the slope is and have to figure
out what the curve is.
Hence the motivation.
Well, at any rate, there'll be
more about this in the text
and in our exercises.
So until next time, good bye.
MALE SPEAKER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.